hello or glad you've joined us for this
live webinar generation of purified
human IPSC derived cardiomyocytes using
clinically relevant workflow I'm Judy
O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provide our
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by Milton E biotech
Milton e biotech is a global provider of
products and services that advanced
biomedical research and cellular therapy
the company's innovative tools support
research at every level from basic
research to translational research to
clinical application this integrated
portfolio enables scientists and
clinicians to obtain analyze and utilize
the cell
Milton e biotechs technologies cover
techniques of sample preparation cell
isolation cell sorting flow cytometry
cell culture molecular analysis and
preclinical imaging there are more than
25 years of expertise spans research
areas including immunology stem cell
biology neuroscience and cancer in
clinical research areas like hematology
graft engineering and a phoresis the
company also offers comprehensive
scientific support consultation and
expert training to learn more visit wwm
elton e biotech comm let's get started
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits you can pose
questions to the speakers during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left
I now present today's speaker Todd Jay
Heron BS PhD director of the Frankel
cardiovascular centers cardiovascular
regeneration Corps laboratory dr. Herron
is on the faculty in the University of
Michigan Medical School and has
appointments in the department of
internal medicine and molecular and
integrative physiology as an associate
research scientist his research is
focused on a complex interplay between
cardiac electrical excitation and
contractile force generation a process
known classically as excitation
contraction coupling excitation
contraction coupling is highly regulated
in the mammalian heart and slight
modifications of this process occur on a
beat to beat basis any dysfunction can
lead to fatal cardiac arrhythmias and
heart failure in this research dr. Haren
has utilized transgenic animals surgical
models of heart failure and more
recently human induced pluripotent stem
cells Hipps es dr. herons lab was among
the first to utilize a chai PSC CM
monolayers to study human cardiac
arrhythmia mechanisms in vitro current
research is focused on developing
patient specific cardiomyopathy disease
models in vitro using h IPS CCM
technology as well as development of
high-throughput screening platforms to
test for compound effects on human
cardiac function a primary goal of the
core laboratory directed by dr. Harun is
to work toward generation of clinically
relevant h IPS CS and h IPS CCMS by
using Zeno free media and non genetic
modification based purification of
derived cells in this endeavor his lab
relies on clinically relevant reagents
from Milton E biotech dr. herons
complete bio is found on the labyrinth
website
dr. Harun will now begin his
presentation thank you Judy very much
for that introduction I'm happy to
present work that I'm doing now in my
laboratory to create unlimited supplies
of human cardiac muscle for research
purposes
so in the cardiovascular regeneration
core laboratory we obtain skin biopsies
from patients and through the process of
cellular reprogramming we create
unlimited supplies of patients specific
stem cells which then enables us to
create unlimited amounts of patients
specific cardiac myocytes and tissue and
we use these cells to work on drug
discovery projects as well as to
determine novel mechanisms of disease we
use platforms such as two-dimensional
cardiac monolayer optical mapping and
arrhythmia study to determine cardio
toxicity we also utilize
three-dimensional organoids
to study structure and function as well
as contractile function of human heart
muscle and our overall goal is to
utilize this technology to create new
and save their appease for patients in
our endeavor to create clinically
relevant cardiovascular cells for
research purposes we utilize an array of
products from Milton a biotech one
product that we use extensively is their
pluripotent stem cell medium which is
called stem max IPS brew and the X F
stands for Zeno free this enables the
generation of induced pluripotent stem
cells and media that is free of animal
products we also utilize their mono
layered Association kit for human tissue
as well as their newly developed PSC
derived cardiac myocyte isolation kits
which is optimized for human cardiac
myocytes now I'm going to show data
which supports the successful
reprogramming of human
dermal fibroblasts using sendai virus in
media that is the IPS bruisy no free
media and in this first slide I show
results using a reporter virus that
carries green fluorescent protein and
here you see successful transduction of
dermal fibroblasts with sendai virus in
the IPS bruisy no free media this plot
shows time-lapse imaging studying the
appearance of GFP expression in dermal
fibroblasts in the IPS brew media in the
next slide we show successful
reprogramming of human dermal
fibroblasts to H IPS CS in IPS brew this
shows time-lapse imaging starting from
day zero where there are dermal
fibroblasts in culture and by day 15 we
observe very robust and very efficient
generation of H IPS see colonies in IPS
Beru and the way that we monitor the
time-lapse imaging is by imaging these
vessels at 2 hour intervals in the
incubator using an instrument called the
inky sight zoom in the next slide I'm
going to show how we perform cardiac
directed differentiation to make a chai
PSC CMS and non CMS so we start with
purified IPS see colonies add a minus 2
shown here in green and we utilize small
molecule based approach for cardiac
directed differentiation we're on day 0
we use a went signaling activator
followed by a went signaling inhibitor
on day 3 then we switch to an our PMI
based media on day 7 and by day 9 of the
story
as we obtain functional cardiomyocytes
and on day 30 after purification and
maturation we obtain very high purity
and very lovely cardiomyocytes with rod
shaped morphology and also with the
appearance of multi nucleation which is
characteristic of adult cardiomyocytes
we now generate these cardiomyocytes in
t25 flasks shown here and using optical
mapping where we load the mono layer
with a fluorescent dye we can actually
observe action potentials shown in this
figure and early in the differentiation
process at day 17 the spontaneous
beading activity of these cells is three
point four Hertz which is the equivalent
of a heart rate of 204 beats per minute
with time moving from day 17 to day 30
of the differentiation process we
observe slowing of the spontaneous
beating rates from three point four
Hertz to two point two Hertz which
correlates to a resting heart rate of
132 beats per minutes so there's some
electrophysiological maturation that
occurs just with time in these vessels
now when we generate these
cardiomyocytes we generate not only the
muscle cells that perform the work of
the hearts but also non cardiomyocytes
are formed and it is important to be
able to separate the cardiomyocytes from
the non cardiomyocytes because the non
cardiomyocytes can have significant
impacts on the function of the
cardiomyocytes so here you see in the
top panel spontaneous recordings of
monolayers made up of purified myocytes
and when we slowly titrate in non
cardiomyocytes there's significant speed
eating of the spontaneous rate of
contraction which gets even faster as
the amount of non muscle cells is
introduced in mixed in with the
cardiomyocytes and this is shown nicely
in the next figure plotting the
conduction velocity of the electrical
impulse of the monolayers and as we
titrate in more and more cardio more and
more non cardiomyocytes the conduction
velocity slows similarly whenever we
quantify the spontaneous beating rates
as the amount of non muscle cells
increases in the monolayers the
spontaneous beating rates significantly
increases so that means it's very
important to be able to separate and
purify the cardiomyocytes from the non
cardiomyocytes there are several several
approaches that have been developed to
purify h PSC derived cardiomyocytes one
of the first approaches utilized a
mitochondrial die combined with flow
activated cell sorting this was
developed in 2010 however drawbacks of
this method include low recovery of
cardiomyocytes and risk of contamination
next a genetic modification and
antibiotic selection approach was used
however this type of genetic
modification is not compatible with
cellular therapy processes or with
high-throughput screening large numbers
of unique patient specific h IPS see
lines for personalized medicine in 2011
of magnetic bead based separation
approach was developed utilizing cell
surface markers one called Serpa 2a this
was reported in 2011 another commonly
used cell surface markers called vkm
1 the vascular cell adhesion molecule 1
and while these were shown to be
effective with time the field is
realized that actually these produced
low viability of targeted cardiomyocytes
and also low recovery of cardiomyocytes
and in our own lab we found a high
degree of user dependent variability
more recently a popular method utilized
for purification of cardiomyocytes is
metabolic stress selection in 2013
medium composed of high lactate and
glucose depletion was shown to purify
cardiomyocytes by essentially killing
off the non Maya sites while the cardio
myocyte muscle cells survive while this
approach is very effective and very
attractive because of its low cost and
ease of use the metabolic stress has
unclear consequences for cardio myocyte
structure and function so recently in
collaboration with Milton a biotech
we've worked with them to create an
innovative purification approach and
this is a new highly efficient and
clinically relevant approach which is
needed for HP SCCM purification and this
innovative approach targets the non
cardio myocyte population for depletion
by specific antibodies and this
consequently enriches the cardio myocyte
population this slide shows a cartoon of
this cell separation strategy for cardio
myocyte purification the results that
have been obtained both in the military
biotech labs as well as my lab at the
University of Michigan have indicated
very high degree of purity up to at
least greater than 90% independent of
the
repoing stem cell line use and the
differentiation protocol and time points
of differentiation and this is a two
step to step strategy that's been
developed strategy a involves depletion
of the non Maya sites so in this
strategy and antibody targets non
cardiomyocytes shown here in green and
in orange utilizing magnetic field these
cells become magnetized and become
trapped in a magnetic field allowing the
cardiomyocytes to flow through and to be
significantly enriched the second part
of this strategy involves depletion of
non Maya sites with subsequent
cardiomyocyte enrichment using surface
to alpha antibodies to target the
cardiomyocytes and to provide further
enrichment of the cardiomyocyte
population this is a result obtained in
the military biotech labs it's been
shared with us utilizing strategy a
depletion of non targeted cells or
depletion of non Maya sites in this case
this shows data from flow cytometry
experiments where cardiac troponin T is
used as a marker for cardiomyocytes here
we can see that in the unpurified cells
there are two populations of cells there
are cardiomyocytes which are cardiac TN
T positive as well as another population
of cells which are making up the non
cardiomyocytes with depletion of the non
Maya sites you can see that this
population cells
this has been on Maya sites if it isn't
faiiure present at very significant
abundance in the enriched cardio myocyte
fraction indicating a very high purity
of cardiomyocytes in fact in this case
BD enrichment enriched the card size to
97 percent purity with
in the cardiac myocytes population the
slide shows the complication of using
strategy a to deplete the nonminor sites
and further enrichment using strategy B
to further enrich cardiomyocytes so in
this slide we see that the
differentiated HP SCS contains just
nineteen point four nine percent cardiac
TNT positive cells and utilizing
strategy a to deplete non myocytes from
the population an enriched the
infraction was obtained up to a purity
of seventy nine point five percent and
then subsequent use of strategy B for
enrichment of cardiomyocytes resulted in
purified cardio myocyte population up to
ninety four point three percent purity
so you can see in stepwise improvement
of the purification of the cardiac
myocytes so this is wonderful because
means that now starting with cardio
myocyte ratios of 20 to 80 percent
magnetic enrichment of h PSC DCMS using
the PSC CF my installation kit human
gives purities up to 97%
in our own laboratory
have tested strategy a depletion of non
cardiomyocytes and today we have tested
eight different achi PSC lines here this
is showing the results of flow cytometry
announces using cardiomyocytes
differentiated from Agip FCS before
purification in this case the
differentiation was a low efficiency of
just 26.6% CT n t+ cells and using
strategy a depletion of non- s we're
able to increase the purity of the
cardiomyocyte population 84.9% we've
used a lot as other cell lines as well
here showing an H IPSC line called 9911
in this case the purity was a little bit
better before purification at 68.4%
cardiac TNT positive cells and following
strategy a we were able to increase the
purity of the cardiac TNT cells up to
about 95% cardiomyocytes and using a
third control cell line called the bji
PSC CM again a purity of about 60% we
were able to increase the purity of
cardiomyocytes up to 96.3%
a very significant increase in the
cardio myocyte purification utilizing
just strategy a so next I'm going to
show data where we went ahead and also
utilized strategy B to further increase
the enrichment of cardiomyocytes so here
shows which with using closed cytometry
to probe for cardiac T and T positive
cardiomyocytes the non purified
cardiomyocytes in this case
were representing 30% of the
cardiomyocyte population we utilized an
old approach using Serpa and we were
able to increase this up to a purity of
50% and when we utilize strategy of new
kids we using non myocyte depletion we
were able to increase the purity up to
around 90 percent pure cardiomyocyte
population
so using CM targeting directly with the
old method using Serpa fell short to
provide purified cardiomyocyte
populations but strategy a on his own
really improved the purity of the
cardiomyocytes population with further
enrichment you like utilizing strategy a
plus B we didn't obtain any higher
purity than using strategy a alone which
indicates this strategy a alone may be
sufficient for enrichment of
cardiomyocytes we also used other
cardiomyocyte markers including mlc 2a
and mlc 2 V these are cardiac myocyte
specific markers and we saw a very
similar trend where the not purified
cardiomyocytes represented 60 percent of
the total cells initially using Serpa
alone we gain no further enrichment and
using strategy a however we were able to
obtain cardio myocyte populations of
greater than 90 percent purity and with
further enrichment by using a
combination of strategy a and strategy B
there was tiny significant increase in
purity however not reaching statistical
significance so it appears to us and in
our laboratory the utilizing just
strategy a is sufficient to create very
pure populations of human cardiomyocytes
now I'm going to present data showing
the structure and function of
cardiomyocytes purified using the Milton
a strategy a approach of non
cardiomyocyte depletion so here in the
upper left hand corner this is probing
for cardiac troponin T in red this is a
muscle protein and in blue are the
nuclei of each cell and you can see
there is very high purity of
cardiomyocytes in this population under
10x objective using confocal microscopy
we also looked at the non cardio myocyte
population just to make sure that we
weren't losing any cardiomyocytes and we
found very little loss of cardiomyocytes
in the non cardio myocyte population
looking under higher magnification using
a 60 x objective to give a better look
at the structure of the cardiomyocytes
we could observe very good sarcomere
stration patterns as well as very good
nuclear localization in the cells and
when we look at the non cardiomyocytes
population we do see some cardiomyocytes
to come through however the majority of
the cells in the non cardio myocyte
population are indeed non cardiomyocytes
here we probe for a cell to cell
junctional protein to make sure that the
purified cardiomyocytes using this new
approach from LTE have very good cell
cell connections here we prefer the
nuclei in blue and we stain for encode
hiren which is the cell to cell junction
protein and green and what we can see is
in between the cardiomyocytes very good
localization and very good expression of
encode here and at the cell the cell
junctions indicating that following the
purification approach the cells do what
they're supposed to do
they make very good tight junctions with
one another and here using strategy a we
found that it is applicable to all of
the HIPC lines we've tested so far at
the time of making the slide we had test
11 different human cell lines and all 11
cell lines were amenable to purification
using the strategy and here shows a
beautiful picture showing the sarcomere
structure probing for cardiac troponin T
shown in pink and n could here in in
green so we're very happy with this new
approach of purification because it
applies to many cell lines every cell
line that we've tested and it has a very
good workflow it only takes about an
hour to complete so in addition to
performing structural analysis we've
also been performing
electrophysiological assessments of
these max purified monolayers utilizing
just strategy a the non cardio - a
depletion approach and so in our
laboratory we create monolayers we load
them with a voltage-sensitive dye called
float volts and we perform multi well
optical mapping utilizing either 96 or
24 well plates we use this diet to
record action potential recordings i'll
show you data recording spontaneous
activations of these monolayers
as well as data from electrical pacing
the electrical pacing that we used is
shown here we utilize a custom frame
fitted with custom electrodes and you
can see in the center of every well a
silver electrode that's used for point
stimulation so that we can synchronize
all of the wells and their contraction
at the same time so this is showing
original recordings of action potentials
so here you can see everywhere that
there is a flash of light descending
case a spontaneous activation of cardiac
monolayer and these cells purified using
the mill tanning approach have a very
good rhythm a very normal rhythm and
importantly when we do the same
recording in the non cardiomyocytes
which are made up of non muscle cells we
do not observe any activations and any
of the cells that we've used so far if
we look at the single pixel recordings
we can see very good rhythm again of H
IPS CCMS purified using this new
strategy from Milton T and in the non
cardiomyocytes since there's very
minimal loss of the cardiomyocytes
there's absolutely no electrical
activity in the non- a population we
also have utilized this to measure
electrical wave propagation here I show
data single pixel recordings from a
single well of monolayers being pasted
at a frequency of one Hertz that's a
rhythm of or heart rate of 60 beats per
minutes so this provides very good
evidence for us that the new approach
provides structurally healthy cells as
well as functionally healthy cells we've
also utilized these cells to mature the
phenotype of cardiomyocytes to enable
high throughput 96-well plate screening
for drug toxicity we're able to actually
control the maturation level of
cardiomyocytes and make them either have
a fetal like morphology and phenotype or
a mature morphology and phenotype and
that is shown here here these are cardio
myocyte so that fetal phenotype the
cardiomyocytes are very circular in
shape
however the mature cells are much more
rod shapes
and much larger and that is quantified
here studying the circularity index
mature cardiomyocytes are less circular
and the mature cardiomyocytes also are
much larger and when we look at the
structure of the mature Maya sites that
can be obtained using the Milton T
approach of purification we can obtain
cardiomyocytes with rod shape morphology
and also with by nucleation within the
cells in our 96 well plate mapping
system we utilize clove oats this is the
excitation and emission spectra of Flo
bulbs the experimental setup that we use
is shown in panel B 96-well plate to
purified Maya sites is put on top of a
temperature controller and utilizing a
high-speed camera we can obtain data
from multiple wells simultaneously to
enable the development of those response
curves using purified cardiomyocytes and
at the moment the array that we use is a
six by six recording array and this
enables very high throughput and very
high speed acquisition of data so in
this assay in the presence of an action
potential the cells will fluoresce green
and we record this using a high-speed
CCD camera we've also utilized a
analysis software system so that we can
perform automated action potential
detection here shows action potentials
recorded from well a four from this
particular well here and our software
that we utilize labels the upstroke of
the action potential in red and the
repolarization phase of the action
potential in green so this enables very
high content very high throughput
analysis recorded data
in an automated way we validated the
responsiveness of these cells purified
using the new kit from Milton II and
we've exposed them to a compound that
has low risk of developing arrhythmias
called tamoxifen and we've also utilized
high risk compounds which are known to
prolong the action potential duration
and cause arrhythmias and here I'll show
you data from a compound called
quinidine so this shows different doses
of quinidine the lowest dose is here at
zero and the highest dose used was 10
micromolar quinidine shown in the top
row of action potential recordings each
flash of light that you see corresponds
to an action potential and what you can
see is the high doses of quinidine
there's a slowing of the action
potential firing rates as well as a
prolongation of the action potential
duration and then action potential
duration in control conditions is about
350 milliseconds and at the highest dose
of this compound which is known to
prolong the QT interval and promote the
development of arrhythmias was prolonged
to 537 milliseconds on the other hand
when we use tamoxifen which is a safe
drug we did not observe any significant
slowing of the spontaneous bleeding
raids and we did not observe any
significant increase of the action
potential duration so this indicates of
the cells that are obtained using this
purification approach to respond to
drugs as one would expect them to
respond so now I'm going to show you
case reports from a study that we
completed recently in collaboration with
the FDA as part of the sip initiative
and for this test we were blinded it was
a blinded phase 2 study for the sip
initiative
I'm going to show you the results for a
compound that we now know is identity
the compound is called perdón is a
dopamine receptor - antagonist and it is
used clinically for parkinson's patients
to treat symptoms of nausea and vomiting
and what we found with is quite
remarkable in using cells or purified
using the Emax technology at the lowest
dose used here relative to the clinical
c-max dose at one c-max we saw a very
good rhythm of the cardiomyocytes
however it does three we could start to
observe action potential duration
prolongation and excitingly at the
highest dose we could actually see the
induction of drug-induced arrhythmias
that cardiologists must be careful of
when they're using this d2 receptor
antagonist so at the lowest dose of
cardiomyocytes purified using this new
approach we saw very good rhythm however
at the highest dose we could actually
observe the induction of early after
depolarizations that are known to lead
to arrhythmias and we could actually
record the transition from somewhat
normal rhythm to ventricular tachycardia
like activation of the cardiac monolayer
now in my lab we've been moving towards
utilizing three-dimensional micro
tissues and we found that for the
development of three-dimensional cardiac
organoids
requires the presence of cardiomyocytes
as well as non cardiomyocytes so the
tissues that we use are shown in this
picture so in this there are six
different tissues the tissues form
around two bendable posts the posts are
shown here as well as here
and we know from our own studies and the
max purification technique that's been
developed has allowed us to more
quantitatively develop these we know
that in purified cardiomyocyte fractions
there will be no tissue formation the
presence of the non cardiomyocytes is
essential for successful development of
these three-dimensional tissues and so
now we're able to utilize this approach
to recombine and make defined
three-dimensional micro tissues with
defined populations of cells these 3d
micro tissues are wonderful they enable
us to actually quantify organogenesis so
here we've developed an assay where
cells are loaded with cell tracker green
and at time 0 the cells combine with
collagen take up the whole well and over
time the tissues form spontaneously
through the work of the non
cardiomyocytes to work with the
cardiomyocytes to reform the collagen
matrix to enable generation of
three-dimensional tissues this shows the
structure of those tissues so here
standing for cell membranes with WGA we
can see that the cells are homogenious
ly distributed throughout the tissue
when we look at the structure we can see
very nice circular structure being
developed in the 3-dimensional tissues
and when we probe for cardiac troponin T
we can see that the cardiomyocytes are
present homogeneously distributed
throughout the three-dimensional tissue
and what's beautiful about this tissue
is that we can use it to measure
contraction and here shows the actual
measurement of excitation contraction
coupling this shows calcium transient
measurements in red with simultaneous
contraction measurements shown in blue
and we can see very clearly that the
calcium transient precedes the
contractile events in blue so this
enables a novel way to study excitation
contraction coupling in a
three-dimensional bio engineered human
tissue so in conclusion the stem max IPS
brew stem-cell media from melting which
is Zeno free is compatible with
generation of virtually unlimited supply
of patient specific cardiomyocytes the
purified population of H IPS CCMS can be
generated without genetic modification
or metabolic stress using clinically
relevant workflows and we're very happy
that the processing time to develop
purified populations has been cut down
to just one hour importantly the
purified h IPS CCMS using the new
approach can be used for
electrophysiology and for arrhythmia
studies and now we're able to
manufacture 3d human cardiac micro
tissues can be done using clinically
relevant workflow and importantly with
defined cell populations and with that I
thank you for your attention and I'm
happy to entertain any questions
thank you dr. heron for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box sound
like clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window
dr. heron will answer as many questions
as time permits the first question is
did the purified cardiomyocytes freeze
and fall will hello yes we've done
experiments using the purified
cardiomyocytes as well as non Maya sites
and we have frozen them and store them
in liquid nitrogen and they do thaw very
well they come back to life they can be
used to reform monolayers as well as to
create functional model layers to have
good electric electrophysiological
function can the purified cardiomyocytes
be recombined with other cell types to
create 3d tissues yes as I showed in the
presentation the separated cells can be
recombined they can even be recombined
following freeze and thein to create
three-dimensional tissues and we've done
this using the platform that I showed in
the webinar and we also have used other
types of vessels and other shapes and
they work very well even though the
identity of the non Maya sites that are
depleted from the cell population we're
doing experiments to determine the
identity of the non cardiomyocytes we
know that they are very highly
expressing a protein called vimentin
which is primarily a fibroblast protein
and also we've started to use some
separation strategies to purify human
cardiac fibroblasts using a similar type
of approach based on magnetic bead
separation so those studies are still
ongoing in every way for questions to
come in I would like to once again thank
dr. Haring for his presentation okay
here's another is there hope
we're using your cardiac cells to
replace dysfunctional in vivo heart
cells that is the ultimate hope for this
technology is to one day to be able to
deliver healthy cells to an infarcted
heart to regenerate essentially dead
regions of the hearts that's our
ultimate goal however that will take
quite a bit of research and quite a bit
of work to be able to get there but
using this approach for the purification
of the Maya sites is a big step forward
to enable defined cell populations to be
used later on for cell therapies okay
and additional questions are coming in
as they come in I would like to thank
you dr. heron for your presentation do
you have any comments for us and any
final comments the only final comment is
that I'm happy to share this data and
our endeavor to create clinically useful
cell types we think that using non
genetic modification of cells is a big
step forward for the clinical use of
these valuable cells that can be
generated in a patient's specific way
and hopefully to lead to personalized
medicine and personalized cellular
therapies another for you can you
recommend a publication or manuscript
that details 3d human cardiac micro
tissues there have not been a lot of
reports on the development of 3d Micro
tissues with defined cell populations
however I know that dr. Murray's
laboratory I believe was in around 2011
and the journal Circulation research his
laboratory did report on the generation
of three-dimensional heart tissue
I believe using human embryonic stem
cell derived
cardiac cells another leading group in
the field is the group led by dr. Ashton
Hagen from Germany and his laboratory
has really pioneered the generation of
three-dimensional engineered heart
tissue they started back in the late 90s
using rat neonatal myocytes to kind of
figure out how to generate 3d tissues
and more recently they've been having
publications come out I believe in the
journal stem cell reports where they've
described preliminary data generating
human engineered heart tissue for cardio
myocyte purification by strategy a is it
also applicable for isolation for mouse
cardio myocyte more than 90%
we've not studied that in our laboratory
we've only studied human cardiomyocytes
I I don't know that the same strategy
can be applied to deplete the mouse non
myocytes
but there are a lot of similarities in
the epitope expression between human
cardiac cells and mouse cardiac cells so
so it may be possible have you compared
yourself against other commercially
available cells yes we recently
completed a study using our 96-well
plate format where we utilized
commercially available cells from
cellular dynamics international called
I cell cardiomyocytes and we compared
drug responsiveness between cells that
we made here at the University of
Michigan purified using this new
approach and compared the responsiveness
to the commercially available cells and
while this cells were similar there were
some aspects of the arrhythmia phenotype
that were different between the two cell
types
variable or the yields of cardiomyocytes
so when we do a cardiac directed
differentiation of stem cells there can
be a pretty high degree of variability
in the yield as I showed in the webinar
sometimes we'll do a differentiation and
obtain 20 to 30 percent cardiomyocytes
other times we can obtain up to 90
percent so the one very attractive
aspect of the magnetic base cell sorting
is that we can rescue essentially a bad
differentiation and still obtain highly
enriched cardiomyocytes following the
purification process thank you thanks
again to dr. Karen and I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would also like
to thank our sponsor Milton E biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the seed button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
December 7th 2017 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye